hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
zu einem weiteren krieg kam letztes mal
so gut deswegen habe ich mir gedacht die
mache heute mir das quiz welches game
shipping sollte dich adoptieren da sind
nämlich auch konkret ich bin schon
wieder raus crafter mit doppel c kran
traf damit kc das ist riecht man man man
sind die matt ö
das ist der grund warum ich mich auf
youtube auch luca umbenennt habe
beziehungsweise umbenennen möchte das
halte ich eigentlich davon wenn das
ganze so ein bisschen persönlicher und
so aber wir fangen an du hast frei was
machst du im internet etwas
recherchieren zocken musik höre machen
essen zocken musik hören wenn ich
freihabe zog ich natürlich was für musik
hörst du metal und alles in die richtung
metal und alles in die richtung aber
außer charts mitteln alles in die
richtung stadt
wieso ist dann nur mittelalter ich höre
eigentlich nicht mal so viel zeit
sondern eigentlich nur so feature haus
und bass haus
aber werde ich war überhaupt kein mittel
deswegen kann ich ein notarzt anklicken
du nimmst einen ferienjob an welcher der
unten aufgelisteten wird am ehesten auf
dich zu sprechen ferienjob gibt's auch
was euch bemühen ja ich nenne das erste
wovor hast du am meisten angst definitiv
insekten spinnen jumps kers nichts kann
mich eigentlich habe ich aber vor gar
nichts angst oder ich meine ich hasse
keine spinne meine lampe flimmert die
ganze zeit
ich meine ich hasse keine insekten wenn
sie wenn ich die auf dem bodensee und
die ganz kleinen sind aber wenn ich
insekten über den ovalen krater ist
wirklich gerade als denn insekten über
mir sind oder eine spinne über mir ist
oder auch wenn ich mal tauchen war und
fische waren über mir immer wenn die
unternehmen gar kein problem aber wenn
ich hoffe und ich sehe die über mir
ich hatte eine lange zeit das immer an
meiner haustür oben eine spinne war
riesig und immer als sie dadurch liga -
oh nein bitte berühren welches der
pärchen magst du am liebsten ich weiß
ist eine blöde verbaut
natürlich muss welches hobbys am
coolsten übernatürliches suchen darüber
lesen musik machen videos let's play und
blogs videos kommen die blogs plötzlich
macht videos komme die blogs und let's
play ist natürlich mit den fans am
coolsten weil ich selber so in die
richtung macht übrigens auch viel mehr
box so sachen zu machen wie das wo ich
eure videos der beantwortung darauf
reagiere aber ich weiß gibt es sowas
schon auf youtube wird sie machen
menschen einer macht ich weiß dass kelly
halt kommentare kommentiert aber gibt
schon jemanden der videos von euch sich
einen senden lässt und darauf reagiert
weiß ich nicht willst du gerne auf achse
ja ich fahre gerne raus ja auch preise
oder party ist mir alles recht geht es
lieber wenn am liebsten zu hause ja klar
ich mache mal ja ob reise oder partys
mir alles recht weil das ich bin ich bin
gerne unterwegs und ich feiere gern tja
hast du einen bestimmten stil nur
schwarz feste klamotten cool nämlich
wird natürlich cool liga das sind auch
ganz normale fragen natürlich bin ich
cool waren was machst du auf der
toilette manchmal zocken muss
für eine schnelle musik ich mache
einfach mal zocken auf toilette bin ich
eigentlich übrigens ich habe ich glaube
ich darf euch gar nicht sagen dass das
spiel schon draußen ist es kommt bald
ein heißes spiel
blue mit drin ist im app store aber gilt
noch bisschen das spiel ist mal wieder
nicht von mir sondern das ist so ähnlich
wie mit dem ukulele spiel wurde nur
gesagt ja es gibt spiel wobei du mit da
drin sein will findet auf dem handy
geben und ich waren zu jeder verdi-chef
socken und ich hab schon diese
testversion
ich kann es gar nicht vor allem auch das
könnte sie auch interessieren nur
sonnenscheins schreibe ich mich eher
verrückt schlauen metzler musik
begeistert auf keinen fall schleudert
ehrgeizig auch nicht nett schlaufe spaß
zu haben
ich mach netz laufen spaß zu haben
welches game shipping sollte dich an
tieren zu 60 prozent sind sie du wirst
von lauter das ziel
freut euch doch die hätten noch das
folgende werden können 20 prozent sie
die werden von desktop tiert die
scheinen tatsächlich sehr viele bilder
zu haben
es gibt ja auch so eine auswertung wie
prozentual gesehen wie oft die
jeweiligen profile angelegt wurden und
das ist ein spitzenwert freunden das ist
super ihr werdet alle von mods adoptiert
dadurch dass ich das jetzt auf mats
gemacht habe kann mir sagen das material
ist
wir machen noch ein quiz und zwar wie
gut kennst du congo after 2002 die
highschool rafters freund formen
eiskappe als ob tag einfach kran traf da
steht mein lieblingsessen ist definitiv
pitzer wo war er dabei
bei minecraft minecraft kunterbunt
wasser denn welche drei sachen hat er
balu wie tätowiert mit doppelte und
doppel l geschrieben oder auch ukulele
wie therapien besser wäre wenn das etwa
ukulele wäre euch sicher dass kunden die
haare mal wieder ab wenn er mich bei den
video days seht ich weiß nicht wann die
sind in berlin habe ich doch schon drei
monaten oder so wer nämlich da seht dann
denk mir bitte eine weibliche ukulele
das ist so witzig hier haben schon so
viele leute auch bei twitter irgendwie
so geschrieben jan-luca wenn du bei dem
video days bis sich bringt den stopp mit
und die bitte stell das dem hintergrund
von den videos nach erbliche seine
komplette stofftier wand wie viele
sachen hatte er vier dreiecken ein auge
3 1 milliarden euro das ist irre
wie soll ich den sabbat beantworten bin
ich eher der ausraster in pose der kein
bock habe der isci ich mach mal der
ausraster wie dann sind normalerweise
einem video auf fünf bis zehn minuten
war er in new york ja faktisch des
kurses ich bin 20 jahre alt das quiz
balleis drücke es lieber und wenn ich
auf die auswertung clique sind wir
sieben von zehn hab ich mir richtig
ich habe einfach kein erfolg bei solchen
krise sogar milch ich habe ja letzte
woche schon mal ein kurs gemacht wo ich
frage mich selbst beantwortet habe das
verdiene ich euch hier das ging genauso
schlecht aus da war ich auch nicht zu
100 prozent ich selbst würde ich das ja
eigentlich alles beantworten sollen tun
könnt was auch immer das war's mit
diesem video meine damen und herren es
euch gefallen hat würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freund schreibt mir die
kommentare ob wir mehr von dieses gute
klar ob ihr mehr von diesen tests haben
wollt und wenn ja welche tests ich als
nächstes machen soll vielleicht von
anderen usern und dieses t shirt was ich
hier gerade an habe ist bei dem ein
schlaf stört dieses t shirt und das
gleich in der farbe schwarz gibt es
natürlich im lukasz ob dies aber die
shop adresse
das wird allerdings nicht mehr
produziert das heißt wenn ihr das nice
findet und ich sagte ja ich hätte das
gerne aber ich würde das erste mal woche
bestellt kann ich nicht garantieren dass
da noch was da ist weil wir es nicht
mehr nachproduziert neues tab kommt und
weil ja auch mit search bald kommt
deswegen wir das ganze nicht mehr
nachgeliefert und habe nur noch den
restbestand der jetzt in lucka shop is
what we say the text